in this video I'm going to go over and
explain how you can program your factory
OEM transmitter yourself without using a
locksmith or an external third party
someone you might have to pay for it to
do the job for you which I'm sure you
all can appreciate here's a few
that I have is a Ford standard kind of
stuff I have a Toyota GM you know a lot
of everyday kind of remotes you might
expect to see up on a key rack now I've
taken the liberty of REM removing and
totally omitting all the transmitters
which are kind of finicky or nightmare
program or the ones that require the use
of an external scan tool or a computer
or a software program anything like that
which would deter you from being able to
do this yourself so know that in advance
I've already done the leg work for you
so if you see this video and you're
watching it um and this is the one for
your specific vehicle which again is in
the title so take notice that if you
have say an 08 GM but you have an 09
thinking it's close enough just do
yourself a favor go to my channel look
in there for your for your specific year
making model there might be another one
that's more relevant so these things are
pretty vehicle specific so take good
care to watch the correct video and I'm
going to do this one a little bit
differently than I've done most of my
other videos most of my other ones are
live action um I sit here do in front of
you do this do this click that and
whatever um this one I chose to do it a
little differently um I've tried to take
screenshots throw it up on there so that
way you could see it and go along with
the video um I've already done about six
or so I've already had people
complaining because the text is too
small goes too fast they can't figure
out how to hit the full screen button or
know how to hit pause so what I've done
is once my my mug goes away it's going
to stop and it's going to be the credits
but on the bottom in the description
area that's where you're going to locate
all your program instructions so at the
end of the video we'll just shut you off
right now just go on down read the
description that's where you're going to
find your information and then just you
could either open it up look at it print
it whatever take it out to your vehicle
and do your thing and that's all there
is going to be to doing these uh
transmitters e